there's so much buzz surrounding this
show I cannot wait to see it with how
excited reef to really get into this
genre this fantasy genre which is one of
my favorite things to watch on TV
well same here actually you know I grew
up being such a fan of the fantasy genre
and of these epic kind of historical
pieces so to be able to you know be
asked to be a part of a project like
this it was really exciting and I
actually signed on before there was even
a finalized script just because I loved
the story and the creative so much so
you know to be able to experience this
and and to be able to be a part of a
story that I feel is so special in such
a fresh take on something that's so
familiar was really exciting and then
you get to play I mean from what I can
see is a super badass character in in
way and you know what was it for you
taking on this role and bringing such an
empowering character to life um I mean
it was it was incredible but I also
think was a great learning experience
you know this role is so different to
anything that I've ever done before not
just in terms of genre but also in terms
of you know learning such a vast array
of skills and also doing that in such a
short period of time and the other thing
you know with this genre is that I love
to watch it and I know so many other
people are as well but it's that kind of
mixture of you know this is something
that is so epic and has such a grand
magnitude and then you're filling it
into a TV series which is like a 10
month shoot so it's basically doing like
an hour film of 10 times in one year and
you know that in itself I think really
opened my eyes to just how much work and
how much time and effort goes into
creating these epic pieces and I
definitely slept for a really long time
after we were out who did you get like
horseback riding a training and sword
training like what was the whole process
leading up to because then I heard the
shooting there's a swamp with mosquitos
I burn oh wow yeah you've got some of
the good stories so it was you know it's
really interesting so we I think I I was
the first person to arrive and that
warehouse was empty like weren't really
any people there and
I think we had about four weeks three
weeks of training where I would I
started doing full day's in
pre-production I would do 14-hour days
where in the morning I would do like
conditioning so my body was getting
prepped for this shoot and then I would
go to Steve dents who is the incredible
compañía slash man behind our stunts our
horse riding our sword fighting and
basically do that for a couple of hours
and I would train with the boys Dan and
Devon and then Gustav was there and then
we were all kind of like together in an
in a hotel for the first four weeks and
then shooting started and once shooting
started it was just like basically like
lock those skills that you've learned
and go it was like you know one thing
after the other after the other learning
on the go and yeah just a really rapid
pace and it was really great to see the
evolution of that and what are you
excited for fans to see not only with
this show of course you know these
characters are beloved by so many people
around the world but specifically
specifically with new way what are you
excited for fans to see with her I mean
there's so many I mean there's so much
about this project that I'm excited for
people to see especially when it comes
to her but I think the the thing that
really stands out in my mind is is just
the fact that we're telling this story
you know yeah
theory in legends is something that were
also familiar with but we've never seen
it told this way before and I don't mean
to say that in a corny way but truly
like we know the character King Arthur
and Merlin and the knights of the round
table but we have never seen the story
of the lady of the lake told before and
she's one of the most powerful and
prolific characters so I think it's very
timely to just see a woman at the
epicenter of this legendary tale and to
also finally see the story behind
Excalibur and behind who this incredible
icon is and speaking of having a magical
sword if you had one in your possession
how would you use it oh there's been a
lot of debate about this and I truly
don't think like I I wouldn't want the
responsibility of having the sword but
as Gustav who is very dear friend and
people so pleased Merlin on the show
said that the people who don't want it
are probably the best people
suited to it but I would still say no
because that is just it's too much power
for one person to have I completely
agree well congratulations on the show
it cannot wait to see all of it thank
you so much